fire
and blood
hey guys pete here i was not expecting a
teaser for house of the dragon to come
out in the middle of the afternoon my
time when literally nothing has ever
come out before but it's here and this
looks pretty amazing this idea always
gets thrown out there whether people
care about game of thrones anymore or
not for as popular as it was and as
generally unpopular as the final season
turned out to be it always comes up
whether people will have a desire to
revisit westeros or not myself i'm still
anxiously anticipating the next book the
winds of winter i'll read that as soon
as it comes out but i kind of got burned
out with the waiting and hadn't really
been drawn to anything short of its
release until recently shooting has been
underway for a while on house of the
dragon and there have been a lot of
leaked set photos popping up and i do
find myself getting sucked into looking
at those it was always so much fun to
look at those when game of thrones was
filming and try to speculate on what was
coming next and while it isn't quite the
same old habits do die hard and when you
add a teaser on top of that i find
myself completely paying attention again
before i get into the teaser i'll give
you a really quick overview of what to
expect from house of the dragon it's
taken from the fictional history of the
targaryen family called fire and blood
by george rr martin the show will be
focusing on the civil war of succession
known as the dance of the dragons that
happened after king becerrus the first
died he had named his only surviving
daughter from his first marriage renera
as his successor before remarrying and
having more children with alison
hightower after his death both sides
known as the greens and the blacks could
make a credible claim to put their
favored successor on the iron throne
different factions back them for
political reasons and things escalated
until war broke out it's called the
dance of the dragons because this all
happened 200 years before the events of
game of thrones when the family still
had a lot of living dragons the other
name given to this period is the death
of the dragons because by the end of it
there are a lot of casualties
as i mentioned the trailer looks
fantastic we get a look at the major
players on both sides some valyrian
steel blades and we get our first look
at the valerians which is another family
with the blood of old valyria who didn't
play a huge role during the game of
thrones timeline one of the first things
that pops out is this new imagining of
the iron throne it still looks like the
same one they used in game of thrones
but they added to it to make it look
more like it was imagined in the books i
guess they can say that later on it was
changed and that's how you get the
consistency between the two shows it's
missing any live action scenes with
dragons but there is this one shot where
it's probably the skull of valerian the
black dread we see renera at different
ages in her life when she was younger
when her father was still alive and she
was known as the realms delight they
cast two different actors emma darcy and
millie alcock to play the role so it's
been known that there would be multiple
timelines involved both appear in the
teaser depicting the character at
different ages during the dance she was
married to her uncle damon targaryen
played by matt smith who is in several
scenes in this trailer including this
really nice looking torny shot where it
looks like he's fighting kristin cole
the targaryen armor here looks fantastic
and you get a pretty good look at his
valyrian steel blade dark sister which
has wings and a dragon egg pommel you
even catch a quick glimpse of a stark
banner in a different tourney scene
which is a nice touch and based on their
shields the jousters here look like
they're from house tarly for sure and
then maybe house coal if you were
wondering i mentioned that we get our
first looks at house valerian we see
corliss who is known as the sea snake
he's an important character with a great
backstory and a group shot where it
looks like they're approaching the
wedding where rhaenyra and lane or
valerian will be married on the green
side of things we see a glimpse of otto
hightower as the hand of the king he
served under viserys and then later we
see his daughter allison running with a
dagger in her hand and it looks like
it's that same cat spa dagger that
showed up in the final season of game of
thrones so it looks like it plays an
important role in both series i'm
guessing that this comes after one of
her sons loses his eye but there's not a
lot to go off of right here there's a
quick shot of king becerris on the
throne holding blackfyre and a shot of
mazaria who's connected to daemon and
even serves as his mistress of whispers
at one point there's a fight inside what
looks like one of house valerian's
castles and so yeah there's a little bit
of everything and just one more time it
looks great and it's really sparked my
interest the costumes are up to the
level you'd hope for and at least in
this edited footage the wigs don't look
that bad to me although they're not the
first thing i noticed so maybe i'm not
the best judge there's no release date
yet but we know it won't be coming out
until next year
no major revelations in what they show
it's still unclear how the timelines are
going to work and exactly how much time
they'll be covering in this first season
the iron throne catspaw dagger house
sigils and valyrian steel blades that
feeling is coming back and i'm excited
to hear what people have to say about
this i think that's a good place to
leave it but let me know what you think
in the comments and what you're hoping
to see please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon